the jurogan experience gilbert godfrey's
a legit comedy legend
is he still in new york city during all
this crazy [ __ ] i'm sure he is yeah
has he caught the the kovid yet i don't
think so
how do you live in new york city stacked
on top of people and not catch it
man it's crazy but they also seem to
have uh
really hunkered down and sort of
sort of you know done a good job at
closing it in i think they got
the [ __ ] scared out of them in the
beginning because they were sort of
embarrassed right
because new york was the first one to
really get it
well you know it's a lot of it was those
nursing home cases yep that's
that's a horrific story man again
people don't even talk about this it's
so bizarre it's like a
almost like a mini genocide what they
did
well they didn't know any better or they
didn't know what to do or
what's weird is when like cuomo goes on
cnn and talks to his brother they don't
even bring it up
creepy um i'm gonna tell you i'm a proud
italian guy
and i can't stand those two guys i mean
i really really
truly dislike them the cuomo brothers
and i hate that people like them oh but
they're chemistry they're good
together it makes me mad what makes you
mad about it
they just are such fake phony
freaking just it just exudes
fakeness to me well if you have to be if
you're going to be on cnn
there's a certain amount of what you do
that's coordinated
and programmed it's just how it is
this is a certain amount of it you know
but
i it seems like uh andrew is uh
over time is having a hard time deal
dealing with uh
questions and [ __ ] andrew's a big
[ __ ] guy
because chris is like six too chris is
the one i dislike the most
yeah well you know you you know about
him going out with
the coronavirus and all that or not
having it or whatever he did
well he went to look at property that he
was developing and some guy yelled at
him you're supposed to be quarantined
and he's like [ __ ] you
they got into it
on the live show he's in his basement
well that was fake
yeah yeah like i'm finally coming out of
the basement for the first time
but in his defense that is what they
would ask you to do they would make you
do something like that if you want to
work at cnn like if you want to work
forget cnn if you want to work on a
television show and they know that this
is an opportunity to film you coming out
of the basement
they go come on chris i was like well
make it like it like
he's like i've been out of the basement
the whole time there he is
ready no back down again okay we'll try
it again one more time
chris i'd like you to come up but this
time just a little less enthusiastic
chris chrome returns to basement from
his basement quarantine
no don't what a doofus it's
it's so phony he gets up there and his
whole family has to play along with it
like
oh here it is finally it's over
i finally made it please stop stop
jamming don't make me
it's unbelievable don't make me supposed
to be an honest
news network well it's
it's a program it's uh it's an
entertainment program about the news
yeah that's really what it is and it's
an opinion program about the news
it's not like just like the ap
okay like associated press you read
stories in the associated press
they're generally like their tone is
very
um it's neutral they're just explaining
facts
you know that's what i i try to read
stuff that's just the facts
and then i'll read opinions on both
sides to try to mess my head up
yeah it's crazy cnn's gone
haywire though man i mean they are just
death is coming to all of us
24 7 a day no matter what is happening
in the news
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience